As you wander through the aisles of the grocery
store, you might find your attention caught
on any number of things.
Frozen pizza.
Cupcakes.
Wine.
And as delicious as all of those things are,
we doubt that any of them undergoes as spectacular
of a transformation as a packet of instant
yeast does when you shoot lasers at it.
Because that is not how yeast always looks.
In the packet, it’s dry and dull.
And when you add water and look under a microscope—
without any lasers added—
yeast are more like stagnant, sturdy, living
bubbles.
So what makes yeast shine so bright
when hit with a laser?
Well, we will get there.
But first, let’s talk about the grocery
store, and why you can buy a packet full of
microbes while you are there.
Because that is where James—
our master of microscopes, our purveyor of ponds—
got these yeast.
He bought them, in the form of instant yeast
that was sitting on the shelf of a supermarket.
And that’s because for most of us, yeast
is an ingredient.
It’s something a recipe calls for, like
milk or sugar.
But yeast is also something much more than
an ingredient.
It’s more like our ally, a friendly baker
on the inside who does so much of the work
for us, as long as we give it a few things
in exchange.
When you buy a packet of instant yeast, what
you are really buying is a lot of
Saccharomyces cerevisiae.
That’s the name of the species, and it roughly
translates to “sweet fungus of beer”.
But it’s known by many other names, like
Brewer’s yeast, Baker’s yeast, and budding yeast.
But those first two names are a tribute to
the role yeast play in helping to make our
beer, wine, and— what we’re going to
focus on today— bread.
If you’ve used instant yeast, you probably
conjure up the image of the tiny, brown-ish
white granules that fill the packet and froth
up when you add water.
Those granules are full of live yeast that
had been dried out for later use, and their
small size is important.
It gives each of those minuscule yeast clumps
more surface area relative to their volume,
helping them dissolve faster when they are
mixed with liquid and hydrated into something
that looks more like these cells.
James is a master of microscopes, not a baker,
so he wasn’t planning to use these yeasts
to make bread.
But yeast, of course, helps us make bread
using the same basic processes that helps
them survive.
So the steps James took to bring these cells
to life can help us see some of the ingredients
and processes that make our favorite loafs
possible, starting out with sugar.
We often describe the size of microbes as
fractions of fractions of millimeters, but
it can be tough to wrap our minds around what
that really means.
Looking at these yeast cells dwarfed by a
few undissolved grains of sugar helps give
a better sense of scale.
Just think of how small a grain of sugar is
in your hand, and imagine just how much tinier
a little yeast must be.
Again, it’s easy to think of sugar and yeast
as two ingredients in bread, one added after
to make the right bit of chemistry happen.
And while that’s true, there’s also a
little more going on.
Sugar is like a bribe that helps kickstart
our yeast friends into action, giving them
the sustenance they need to get moving.
As the yeast feeds, they begin to divide,
forming smaller daughter cells that bud off
from their mothers.
You can see some of those buds here, forming
ovals that branch off the circular mother cell.
This is where the name “budding yeast”
comes from, and it’s yet another way that
yeast is different from our other ingredients.
Sugar doesn’t make more sugar, but for yeast
replication is one of their objectives, driving
the growth and survival of their population.
But as the yeast accomplishes their goals, they
happen to get some of our goals done as well.
As the yeast digests sugar, they produce byproducts:
various organic acids, ethanol, and carbon dioxide—
which you can see here in bubbles expanding
and pushing against the field of yeast.
We are watching these bubbles grow in water,
and over the next few minutes, their edges
will push further and further out until these
two bubbles seem to take over the screen.
But in bread dough, those carbon dioxide bubbles
cause the entire structure around the yeast
to expand and to rise.
And when the dough is moved to the oven, the
carbon dioxide will shape the bread that forms.
The ethanol byproduct isn’t visible like
those carbon dioxide bubbles are, but in bread
dough, the evaporation of ethanol also helps
the bread rise in the oven.
And it will also shape the flavor of the bread
that comes out.
While it is making bread for us, the world
inside the yeast is busy as well.
Buried in dough, it’s impossible to see
what that means.
But microscopes are powerful tools when it
comes to digging up seemingly invisible forms
of beauty, especially when they have lasers
in them.
With a microscope that sends a laser of UV
light straight at the yeast, molecules inside
the organism begin to fluoresce, a display
called autofluorescence that lights up the
whole screen with rings of red and green and
yellow that press up against each other and overlap.
To scientists who know how to crack the code,
those colors create a map of the molecules
inside the cell.
Those colors are actually the amino acids
and vitamins that make the yeast work, rising
and falling throughout the yeast’s life
cycle to provide the organism with what it
needs to survive.
It’s as if someone turned on the lights
at the factory, illuminating all the processes
that make the final product possible.
And if we could dedicate a whole episode to
the stunning autofluorescing patterns of yeast,
we would.
But there is one big challenge.
You may have noticed that the videos we’ve
been showing of this are pretty short.
Most only last a few seconds before we switch
to another video.
And that is because those bright lights quickly
fade after being struck with the laser.
Let’s sit here and watch this group of yeast,
initially bright red and green.
After only a few seconds, the red is already
gone.
And as more seconds pass, the green becomes
more and more faint, like someone has been
turning the brightness on your screen down
at an agonizingly slow pace.
After a full minute, the screen has gone completely
black, with no hint at the vivid scene painted
across it so recently— almost as if it had never
been there to begin with.
But even as the lights fade, the factory remains.
Every day, perhaps in your kitchen or in the
bakery around the corner from you, there is
a group of invisible budding bakers occupied
with turning sugar into carbon dioxide and ethanol.
However transient their lives or their work,
the legacy they leave…well,
there’s no arguing with that.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
The people you're seeing on the screen right
now, those are our Patreon patrons.
They're the ones who make it possible for
us to get the yeast packets which aren't that
expensive, but also so that we have access
to the lasers, which are actually not that cheap.
If you would like to become a patron on Patreon,
you can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
There you can get a bunch of cool perks and
also just know that you're making it possible
for this to exist.
If you'd like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.